with people not knowing that asexuality
exists it comes with people constantly
trying to debunk your identity all the
time our culture can often seem highly
sexualized yes I'll have what she's
having
but what if that's just not for you yeah
yes so just sex repulsive and yes a
sexual or ace people don't experience
sexual attraction I don't get that I do
am I meant to get that is is that what
I'm like missing so what is being ace
all about
I'm meeting for people with very diverse
experiences of their ace lives
[Music]
I as hi you're asexual and you're
modeling in this kind of very highly
sexualized environment and yet you
yourself feel no sexual attraction how
does that work it works with me being
very picky with the concepts and the
shoots that I take on I don't want to
produce images that seem like they're
aimed at titillating somebody I'm
literally just here to show off the
clothes and make it look good I'm not
trying to sell myself I'm selling a
product a lot of people don't even
understand what asexuality is what is it
for you
it's thought experiencing sexual
attraction which probably saves me a lot
of time
I'm also a romantic so I don't pursue
romantic relationships either so I
pretty much live life like a normal
person - that element there are a lot of
asexual people who are still interested
in romantic relationships just - the sex
I've never been romantically inclined
either to find out exactly what the
British public knows about asexuality a
Skye data poll asked how confident
people were in defining the term half of
the population said they could
confidently define what asexuality is
but when put to the test three and four
people were unsure about whether asexual
people experience a sex drive or
incorrectly thought that they don't
asexuality is a completely valid sexual
orientation for about 1% of the
population but the public seems to think
it knows more about it than they
actually do I think what it says about
us is I think there's still a lack of
understanding about the diversity that
might exist with sexuality we're getting
better but we're certainly not there and
I think there are so many misconceptions
about what asexuality is how it can
exists in individuals from from birth
really and that that forces people then
to have to make choices that they
shouldn't like to make and their sexual
especially not feel like something might
be missing in your life no I have
friends good relationships of my family
so not worrying about satisfying a
partner does not take anything out of
like I'm absurd I'm happy with my
social situation and I'm also quite
introverted so I don't need a lot of
social attention so yeah it works they
need a lot of social center but you do
do modeling and you do put pictures
yourself out there you see where I find
like yeah well someone might see their
contradiction yeah but that's like
literally I post the picture I continue
of my day I do a shoot today I do
nothing all week
one thing you talk about is what an
asexual person looks like yeah tell me
about that well I actually started a
hashtag cold this is what a sexual looks
like and I pretty much just thought of
it because there are a lot of
stereotypes surrounding asexual people
oh you're supposed to be really shy and
introverted and unable to socialize
properly and probably not very
good-looking I think there's a weird
correlation where people think that you
can't get dates or you can't get laid
and that's why you're asexual so I
thought that instead of relying on the
media to represent asexuality for how
diverse it is I thought let's give the
agency to asexual people so they can
show who they are
[Music]
with her modeling work Yasmin is helping
a sexuality break free from the
constraints of damaging stereotypes
[Music]
Tom and Steve winter gray are an asexual
couple who've been married of eighteen
months
they met through an asexual dating
website and are looking to adopt kids in
the near future
unlike Yasmin they've chosen to pursue
romance
despite their asexuality we both
identify as aromantic asexual so we are
attracted to males they had a romantic
capacity there is nothing sexual about
my attraction determined attraction to
me this isn't a bromance it's not just
with best friends there's more to it
than that we have lots of people as
conceptual not having said how do we
know that we love each other
one of the ways that we normally go back
to that all cam drought that is just
coping to understand that you've got a
mom and a dad and a brother and sister
and Aunty and uncle dogs have pets you
name it and you love them or not we say
yes we do said you won't have sex with
any of them said no I don't ever there
you go
next time I work too much I think a lot
of people talk about how sexual
chemistry needs to be here it needs to
work together and their ways away it
works for us because there isn't any
less tell me about how you came to the
realization that you're asexual so I
always knew that I wasn't straight but
obviously when you were a kid or a
teenager you don't really think about
things other than being straight gay by
actually the scene the gay scene was not
where the most comfortable I felt more
comfortable and have one-to-one
situations of people or wasn't interests
in the sex side of things so I went
online to find out some more information
about different sexualities and
discovered a set Rosie there's a time
only wait wait use the word asexual
learn what you meant ah yeah I mean it
was it was a click but it was also kind
of a period of kind of transitioning
it's like getting youths identity I
think originally I felt that if you're
asexual you couldn't love anyone you
couldn't be in a relationship you could
be locally inside or you like the
airport though I can't be me but I do
like guys romantically
as far as I understand what I've
understood about asexuality recently is
that you can
sexually you might masturbate but this
is about social attraction being
outwardly is that right is that social
geared like being outwardly express it's
it's almost like the person that you are
in your in your head versus who you are
as a you know physical biological person
just because we don't have sex in the
same with other asexuals well it doesn't
mean that there are certain biological
functions that we don't cooperate it
okay it's in that to human function
what's interest is people seem to have
this wonderful wonderful sense of
wanting to be really involved in
something that they wouldn't ever ask
him here or regardless who whoever
orientation or whatever identity uh-huh
they'd never be involved in that they've
never seen it but they seem as though
the rules know more about the fact that
we don't do it Tom and Steve are
confident and comfortable in their
sexuality but getting to that place has
been a very long journey for both of
them I have come away and realized that
I am really really proud of my sexuality
hello I'm asexuals and I love it I don't
know when you drink that Emmy is at the
start of her eighth life
[Music]
she's an eighteen year old student who
vlogs about asexuality and YouTube
honestly student life can revolve around
partying drinking and hooking up do you
not feel like you're missing out I don't
I do often see like people a party is
just kinda like making out with
strangers clubs I think especially when
it's really people that you don't know
and like I've been out with some friends
in a pub before and this guy is really
cute can we like maybe try and like talk
to them and then like this and that and
I've just kind of been like I mean sure
if you want I don't mind and one of the
big worries I had was the Uni room walls
are very thin okay so does sex repulsive
and yes the for me I'm very disconnected
from the concept of sex and kind of
almost like imagining like certain
people that I've known like kind of
before they were in like relationships
or whatever like in a sexual
relationship they just kind of makes my
brain just kind of like crash a little
bit because I've not known this person
as like a sexualized person they're just
this person some people might say you're
very young this is a great opportunity
for you to explore your sexuality and
try different things what's your answer
to that well it's kind of like I know on
a base level the I'm just not interested
in sex I've been in situations where I
could hit someone or wear like one of my
friends has been like I mean would you
want to like kiss someone like at all
and I'm like I don't think so I I just
don't think I get the appeal of it but
not in the same way that I don't like
the idea of sex do you think there's a
lot more asexual people in this world
then we realize I think potentially yeah
I'm the kind of comments that I
currently get on my youtube are the kind
of comments the little fifteen-year-old
Amy left on other people's and to me
that is
I'm sane so definitely might be more
people the effects and spectrum than
anyone really knows
the diverse asexual community is finding
its voice whether through Yasmin's
modeling Emmys YouTube channel or the
dating sites that brought Tom and Steve
together there's a growing and vocal
community that's no longer willing to be
defined by those who aren't ace
[Music]